[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app you know
what are we [ __ ] Brian Callens bank
account nope
welcome to episode 120 of
congratulations it's on it is so it is
so on this is the best 120th episode
we've ever done so and it's about to
it's about to go down with [ __ ] zero
dents I'm sporting my [ __ ] wouldn't
make a dent t-shirt that you can get on
the [ __ ] podcast on the on the on my
website course a combo here's the deal
dude we're going live on my app you can
download the Chris D'Elia app and all
that at at wherever they are our apps
honestly so just go do that type in my
name and you can watch it live before
anybody gets to see it and I've got some
dates this weekend May 18th I will be in
Edmonton and there are still tickets for
the later show and Victoria BC on
Vancouver Island I will be on May 19th
at the Royal Theatre and there are still
tickets left on The Late Show there are
only a few tickets left though so go
ahead if you live in Canada and my
babies let's have a [ __ ] some let's
have a cult meeting okay that's the wind
spear theatre and the Royal Theatre
it's pretty [ __ ] [ __ ] to call your
theatre the Royal Theatre about whatever
what everybody got Lords performing what
do you have beheadings now you don't
yeah so I'm all [ __ ] bummed out
they're making a documentary on my
[ __ ] shoulders
if you call my Instagram it's called
[ __ ] blah boom I tried everything to
do to I tried everything to stop it I
call my agents I was like dude they
can't be making this documentary about
my shoulders and my shoulder workouts
it's called [ __ ] butt boom and it's
so [ __ ] annoying but I can't stop it
dude I'm walking around town they got
film crew after me and they're like what
so like with shoulders how do you
[ __ ] how do you get jackets on you
know and I'm like well you know they get
on but they're tough to take take off mm
anyway dude I couldn't stop it and
they're gonna call it baboom which is a
huge [ __ ] disgrace but whatever dude
we're living life and life's good
you know it's like it's like it is dude
you know what I did [ __ ] man I had
the worst night's sleep dude I had the
worst night's sleep two nights ago I'll
tell you what man when I was a kid I
used to get scared like as a as I if
you're a listener if you've listened to
every [ __ ] episode you know that I
used to get real scared when I was a kid
and I used to run into my parents room
and [ __ ] and then my dad be like what
are you scared of that's another thing
we're always like everything birds but
as I got older I wouldn't really get
scared at like I when I was a kid I was
scared of like ghosts and [ __ ] and and
like but now I'm scared of like real
[ __ ] and I clicked on this video late at
night which was a big mistake first of
all I don't even know you know how you
go into like a rabbit hole of
YouTube videos I saw I started clicking
on I saw these five there was like five
scariest things it's like top five you
know like they were doing that [ __ ] and
and and and let me see if I could find
the [ __ ] but it was so there's a top 5
scariest here we go history
scariest here's one okay top 5 scariest
top 5 secret rooms it's called five
secret rooms found and strangers living
in other people's houses dude and like I
watched this thing it's always the guy's
voice that's that like first of all
static if there's static in the
beginning of your [ __ ] video you're
gonna [ __ ] have to hold your [ __ ] in
because it's scary as [ __ ] like anytime
here why is that scary are we just
trained to let's got to be trained like
if we were just born and then heard
static it can't be scary but there's
that full of [ __ ] that's so scary bro
if you were alone in your house and you
heard that immediately you like this oh
oh [ __ ] oh god [ __ ] [ __ ] came out a
little bit and then the guy's voice
which is always so normal like if they
tried to make the voice scary if it was
like tap five secret rooms and strange
visitors it wouldn't be scary but this
guy just pops in he's like secret rooms
in strange Vidur it makes five secret
rooms and strange visitors first of all
sounds s too drunk he sounds wow he's
not even out drunk because top five
secret rooms and strange visitors oh so
drunk dude top five Street secret rooms
and strange visitors anyway I watched
this [ __ ] thing and one or two of
them are fake like doors like this guy
set up a video camera he's like dude
like I I kept getting on my girlfriend
because I'll go to sleep and I wake up
and there would be less food in the
fridge and I would blame my my
girlfriend eating my [ __ ] Cheez Whiz
until she said it wasn't her so I set up
a camera and then there's like there's a
[ __ ] lady that comes out of that top
cupboard and like eats it and pisses in
the sink and it's like that's so fake
obviously then there's real [ __ ] of like
well here let me just play a little bit
of it standing outside there have drawn
here's your wall friends in the wall
major user Donovan Peter
posted a strange picture that his
daughter had drawn it showed him his
wife his daughter Sophia and his son Tim
all standing outside their house eerily
there were also two extra figures look
man let me tell you something man if I
have a kid and he draws the family and
there's two extra figures in the drawing
up for adoption
see you later dude guess what we can do
not only can we remove the two extra
figures we can also remove where you
drew yourself dude ha rip it up also she
made [ __ ] one of the brothers look
mad as [ __ ] with eyebrows dude how
horror movie is that though how annoying
is every horror movie when they're like
they drew a picture and they're like so
yeah they often draw and then they draw
there's like a picture of a demon as
like who's that and the kid knows some
[ __ ] I'm so sick I'm so done with the
kid being the [ __ ] thing I remember I
saw this movie called identity I think
it was called with John Cusack and at
the end I'm ruining the movie but also
the movie ruins the movie for you so
it's okay and the kid at the end was
like the thing the bad guy that like
blew up everything and I was like
alright enough what the kids did we get
it kids are creepy
it's never the kid in real life it's
never the kid it's always the adult with
the fat belly that [ __ ] abducted the
kid do you know what I'm talking about
you always what it's always like all but
is the kid and the kid is creepy like
they did that [ __ ] way back in [ __ ]
the movie with the shining it's not the
kid with the two daughters the shining
you know the twins it's not the kid
anymore stop making movies where the kid
is the [ __ ] thing and the kids like I
know something you don't know the only
thing you know that you don't is that
you prepared sometimes because your kid
say yeah so this video goes on to
explain how there was like a secret room
this these college kids were living on
campus like close to campus and there
was a secret underground room and he
kept hearing [ __ ] and then he found out
that there was like a hatch and he went
in and there was a go hole
I guess like a homeless person living
under
they're housed in their basement they
didn't know they had now
hat dude that's legitimately the
scariest thing that I can think of
because it's real and I was up for hours
I was up for hours thinking about I hope
no one's also living in my house
top five secret rooms and strange visit
top five secret rooms and slims visitors
visitors dude imagine someone else is
living in your house first of all how
dumb do you have to be for real
you could be Bruce Wayne you could be
that guy who's that guy Tai Lopez and
have 40 rooms and just be taking
Instagram videos all around your rooms
if there's anyone living in your [ __ ]
house it doesn't matter how many rooms
you have you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude I
could own a building I can own a
government building with government
workers and if at night I go to bed and
there's anyone in those rooms and I
don't know it I'm an idiot because dude
if there's someone if it's your place
and you don't know that's a college kid
by the way it's so college kid did be
like dude [ __ ] dude no it's like I
thought it was you know they were like I
heard no I know I heard stuff for sure
but I just thought it was Tim yeah but
Tim doesn't live with you no I know but
he's always trying to like hook up with
chicks in the basement and [ __ ] and like
he comes in out of [ __ ] oh man dude
there was a guy homeless guy and then
and then there was another one where
like this guy was in his house and this
chick was staying in his attic dude oh
what's scarier than what's scarier the
basement or the Attic I don't know man
to think of like a [ __ ] girl like
over see
you it attic also attics are like always
they always like have that [ __ ]
pointy [ __ ] at the top what he called a
frame houses so like so like at the a it
they would be at the end and the end
would be really small and [ __ ] like
it from the wall up to the - you know
I'm talking about because the the roof
goes all the way down so the the part
where there would be would be like
[ __ ] four inches wide from from
bottom to top because that's where the
roof starts and apparently this girl was
in like a [ __ ] in in in like a corner
of the Attic that the guy didn't even
know he had a set idiot and and he went
up and he was like and he was like hello
and she was like Jake and she knew his
[ __ ] name and he was like hello I'm
gonna call the cops and she you're in my
place and she was like you're in my
place ah oh dude I'm my eyes watering
right now that's how scared I am bro Hey
look here's the deal if it's a guy
that's like it's my place you're like
alright dude I'm about to throw down
okay I'm about to throw the [ __ ] down
this guy thinks he's out tough he's
tougher than I am
we're gonna fight maybe I'll die but at
least I know what's up dude at least I
know what's up this is gonna be a
[ __ ] mano a mano fight we're gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna throw gotta throw
hands I'm not I'd like to say throw
hands but there's gonna be hands thrown
okay and and I know what's up I opened
the door and it's [ __ ] I think Iron
Man vs. Captain America okay but dude if
it's if you're like hey you're my house
and you hear a girl it's my house
oh whoa well guess what dude it's a
ghost because no girl unless it's a girl
who's insane in which case she's just
gonna be like clawing at you and just
but it's a ghost it's a hundred percent
of ghosts because no [ __ ] female
knows you know I'm gonna for
me versus a girl I win baby but a ghost
in that parishioner dude you're an
apparition if someone's in your house
and it's a lady voice congratulations
you can't punch it cuz you could walk
right through that person that's the
scariest [ __ ]
squatter's dude Wow
how much balls do squatters have man
that's just you know you're in my house
you know what I swear to God
hey this is me hello Chris yeah
excuse me ma'am you're in my house no
you're in my house I go like this oh
sorry I had the wrong house and I leave
you're right if you're in my house past
eleven in you're arguing that this house
is your house I'm not my house
see you later I'll get a new house dude
cuz you're a ghost
ha [ __ ] out of here dude and then I
watched another one and it was like top
five this whole top five [ __ ] it's
always annoying when somebody does
anything top five but top 5 scariest
there we go
scariest things caught on GoPro camera
specific the top 5 scariest things
caught on GoPro camera I so drunk
Trainspotting top 5 scariest things are
caught on a GoPro camera so some of them
are like these guys got caught in it in
a train tunnel and he was like only
gonna run the train's coming
I said idiots so don't go in a long
train tunnel that's all good but there
was one where he these kids went to this
abandoned insane asylum dude how wide is
it to go to and imbed abandon insane
asylum
how white is it to do that to be like
well it's pretty good man do you want to
go see if we can get possessed
everything's pretty good man parents are
still together got money everything's
good
don't really have too many problems
let's go see if we can meet Satan the
whitest thing
so they go to the [ __ ] insane asylum
and they [ __ ] catch a another guy
they're using a cell phone and it's in
the middle of nowhere dude and it of
course are spray paint on it because
whenever something is a man and there's
spray paint on it for some reason just
like whenever something's creepy there's
static I'll play a little bit of it
is for the other they see a guy
let's go back to the car up literally
have you ever heard anybody more scared
than that listen to that dude though I
that's hilarious listen to how scary
listen to how scared this guy is right
here this so scary right here
let's go back to the car the way he says
car let's go back to the car
Oh oh wow
oh wow dude let's go back to the car
Oh gonna cry oh by the way crying me if
I see a guy with a cell phone out and
abandoned [ __ ] first of all I'd never
do that but so many woods and [ __ ] I'm
low gear look at that they're in the
insane time looking out of it at the
stairwell and there's this guy III it
doesn't you can't really see a [ __ ]
guy it's like oh is it a guy or is it
not a guy and he's got like a CLA that's
there's a light or something but he
wanted to talk to us
oh wow how scary you went when the guy
goes off oh what that so scared we said
let's go to the car now and waffle or
right this way
get somebody wanted to talk to her
what Oh oh my god
he's so scared so the guy does even
noise things because there someone
wanted to talk to us like no dude so I
see that immediate tears immediate tears
streaming down my face and [ __ ] coming
out of my [ __ ]
loud Laura Laura Laura like that oh is
that a guy what screaming we gotta go
they're gonna car dude we got a good car
dude I'm getting [ __ ] all over my Easy's
oh oh dude there's [ __ ] in the back of
my knee man we gotta go dude we got to
go and it's on my hand it's on my adidas
let's go come on let's go let's go dude
let's go come on buddy any guy that's
like way too and also let me tell you
another thing too if I was in this
situation and I was the guy that was
like here we gotta go
because I would be that guy and then
there was another guy that was like dude
it's enough he would get to the first
syllable of nothing and then he and then
I would be not he would be on I would be
just knocking the [ __ ] out of him right
there dude is the BAM he's down I pick
him up we go to the car as I'm carrying
him [ __ ] all down my to my ease ease
that's it why are we here in the first
place apparently I was drugged because I
would never [ __ ] do this we got there
and what are we doing there's a guy out
there oh really we got to go but it's
not BAM hint over my shoulder all the
way over to the [ __ ] Civic that's
what we do dude yeah let's go to the car
I mean so goddamn scared let's go to the
car
wow that's hilarious when somebody
scared yeah let's go to the car uh
realizing realizing they're [ __ ]
yeah so let's go to the car they just my
that's so funny when somebody just
realizes how [ __ ] they are and they're
like this is what gotta do let's just
get it done right it's so funny to when
you're scared and some you're like so
you'll start mentioning [ __ ] that's just
so not scary that's like but it's still
freaking you the [ __ ] out you're like
yeah look like a cell phone
it's a cell phone like when is a [ __ ]
sefelt and scare you so I'm right here
the blazer on yeah you see the blazer
dude the place were at with the [ __ ]
it was a double peace suit it was a
double peace suit dudeney and a pants
were matching he had a full suit on and
you're like okay who did he just [ __ ]
was he just out was he just had [ __ ]
Hugo Boss okay dude there's a guy with
the [ __ ] cell phone dude you saw the
cell phone you saw the [ __ ] homepage
and you're a picture of a [ __ ] woman
and a baby on his [ __ ] home thing on
the cell phone and it is obviously his
family and he had a full blazer on with
the [ __ ] matching pants and it was a
double breasted suit dude so you tell me
you tell me man and you're like um yeah
you're right Hugo Boss kill to go to the
car yeah what looks to be someone using
a cell phone is walking around just
outside the building does it look like
again keep in mind this institution was
in the middle of nowhere there were no
other cars around and no reason for
anyone else to be there elq's he set out
so it's all good and no reason for
anyone else to be there loves Elks dude
and no reason for anyone else to be
there anyone else um yeah so I watched
that and I stayed up till [ __ ] Oh
dark thirty so it's all good so it's all
good got scared woke up was sad you ever
have one of those days where you just
wake up saddest [ __ ]
cups add like bomb to like blue and it
was a nice day dude and I just didn't
know what to do man
nothing was fixing it man nothing was
fixing it
people would hug me and I would just go
yeah you know didn't work out though if
I worked out it would help Mother's Day
was just sad too it just woke up sad it
was sad the whole day hate some food got
nauseous went to bed went to [ __ ] bed
uh yeah why does that happen I don't
know I don't know why that happens I
wasn't sure about that but it's sad when
that happens you know what else is sad
dude what's happening to Constance will
her show got picked up what do you see
this on [ __ ] Twitter when she was she
was doing uh she was like oh my show got
picked up fresh off the boat I think
it's called and she was like [ __ ] I'm
pissed I'm so sad right now
likes ungrateful it because she became a
[ __ ] like TV star doing this [ __ ]
Constance Wu was actors Lampoon
Constance Woo's was is a reaction or a
show being renewed what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know so upset right now that
I'm literally crying oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] hell she writes and then
somebody but and then was a post on
Instagram and she was congratulations
for being for it being for it being
picked up and she writes dislike and
then she tried to go on about how like
first of all just like the four to make
a [ __ ] show on air is so hard like 1%
of actors and then and then she [ __ ]
complains it's just so shitty to the
rest of her crew and and she's a
complete [ __ ] obviously obviously I
mean and then and then she her apology
was even better but
apology which it wasn't even really
apology was just fine you don't have to
apologize if that's how you feel sure
okay fine just so ill-timed but the end
of it go to the end this is the best
people can hold conflicting feelings in
their hearts that conflict is a part of
being human so I can both love the show
Cass crew but at the same time be
disappointed that I lost that other
unrelated job of course you can I
appreciate those who have given me the
space and faith to believe what I say
about both parts of my heart thank you
it's meaningful when you make the choice
to believe women like trying to wedge in
that like women are victims like yeah oh
yeah or you're just a [ __ ] [ __ ]
how are you the victim here
you were shitty to everyone and you're
trying to use women who are victimized
as your platform to [ __ ] well you
know believe women oh I believe you're
an [ __ ] I mean dude other people were
bashing her and and she and and other
cast mates of hers for retweeting those
tweets
you're obviously a deque believe women
yeah how could you use that there's real
women out there being victimized because
they're women and just cuz you were a
[ __ ] about your cast and crew you're
like well we should believe women oh you
ruin this kind of [ __ ] you ruined this
movement that's the worst thing a
[ __ ] woman can do nowadays is to just
use that moment like that was way worse
than I was actually when she was like
[ __ ] this show that's hilarious to me I
was like ah man maybe I'm a [ __ ]
Constance Wu fan but then when she did
this [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of here dude get
out of here next you know what dude next
these [ __ ] actors think that they are
like irreplaceable dude
next you think people give a [ __ ] nobody
gives a [ __ ] about you nobody gives a
[ __ ] about you you're replaceable dude
unless you make yourself not replaceable
which you haven't dude you are lucky you
got on a show and it's a hit and then
you were wasn't she in rich crazy Asians
or whatever the [ __ ] crazy rich Asians
you're lucky dude be happy with that so
now you can't do roles that [ __ ]
challenge you as an actor as you say
alright do it on your offseason take all
the money you made and [ __ ] fund it
yourself and do it in the offseason
boo-fucking-hoo man get out of here
believe women she says because she was
an [ __ ] to her cast and crew nobody
nobody doesn't believe you that you were
a [ __ ] that you said that [ __ ] that
you said that you nobody doesn't believe
you that you want to do that project
nobody doesn't believe you that you that
you that you sure you like doing the
[ __ ] the show and you are upset you
didn't do that you can't do the project
sure nobody doesn't believe you who
gives a [ __ ] that's cool you're still an
[ __ ] for saying it on Twitter and I
love how she's like whatever I use the
word [ __ ] freely you shouldn't be soaked
that's not what we had asked you about
that's not what people have there's
[ __ ] struggling out there actors out
there that are like oh this woman is
[ __ ] cashed out because of luck and
and you [ __ ] and your and and and and
you because you're making about because
you said [ __ ] nobody gives a [ __ ] you
say [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] who
cares you're being an [ __ ] to
everyone on the crew what you do is
after that is a you know what I'm sorry
I actually really do like the [ __ ]
show I was bummed I didn't have a
project that I couldn't do that I have a
project now I can't do because the shows
picked up that was wrong and I'm an
idiot why can't people just [ __ ] do
that why the [ __ ] can't people just do
that
these actors do they think that there's
nothing you know some of them not all of
them obviously but some of these actors
they just think that they're just the
[ __ ] irreplaceable dude if that let
me tell you something if they got rid of
that [ __ ] woman on that [ __ ] show
and just bounced her and didn't write
her out and didn't do [ __ ] and didn't
didn't say [ __ ] about it didn't replace
her they just the next episode BAM she
wasn't in it none of the characters set
up said [ __ ] about it that show would
still be a [ __ ] hit nobody gives a
[ __ ] about you dude nobody gives a [ __ ]
about you period
just like it's just insane whatever
I guess I'm heated but it's like dude I
dude I [ __ ] it's like we we all work
so hard as actors as [ __ ] comedians
and [ __ ] like that and looks like you're
just you're gonna get on up this [ __ ]
bought you your houses do you know what
I mean
and you're just gonna [ __ ] do that to
the peep to the gaffer you know what I
mean to the guy who's so happy that he's
got a [ __ ] job holding a microphone
man for six years and he could pay for
his [ __ ] kids
meals and you're just gonna be like aw
[ __ ] my show got picked up and you're in
your [ __ ] on your chaise lounge on
the off on the on the [ __ ] off room
of your bedroom in your reading room
you're just gonna be like oh [ __ ] my
shows picked up like what an [ __ ] me
undies you probably spend about 90% of
your life in your underwear so don't you
think you owe it to yourself to make
sure you're wearing the softest undies
in town that's why I only wear me undies
and I do and I got them on right now
baby the older I get the more
comfortable I want to be and me undies
helps me take care of that my undies
uses the coveted the coveted micro moto
fabric which is a full three times
softer than cotton and dude if you
haven't experienced it put it on your
thighs it's unbelievable it really is
dude men can now try the new boxer-brief
with fly which is the same great cut as
boxer-brief but now with an added option
for guys who prefer to go through the
gate versus over the fence which I don't
I go over the fence but if you go
through the gate
I mean undies got you covered no no pun
intended me on DS has a great offer for
my listeners for any first-time
purchasers when you when you buy any me
undies you get 15% off and free shipping
get 15% off a pair of the most
comfortable undies you will ever put on
that's me endorsed to get your 15% off
your first pair free shipping and one
hundred percent satisfaction guarantee
go to me Indies comm / Congrats that's
me Indies dot-com / Congrats
Equipe it's time for some spring
cleaning quips got an easy way to start
with your brushing habits two minutes
twice a day can help pave the way to a
healthier mouth and mind and now the
whole family can get refreshed with quip
the new kids quip if you're a parent you
gotta get your kid involved with
brushing your teeth brushing their teeth
same the same two minute timer and
guiding pulses as our original version
which with no childish gimmicks so they
can brush up like a grown-up kids are
always like I want to be a grown-up so
give them the quip thing each two
minutes you go from side to side kid you
want to be an adult get with the program
take this thing that's really sleek and
designed nice every two minutes and then
move you're a kid or your grown-up
you're both if you want to be
kid-friendly features like a small brush
head watermelon act anti cavity
toothpaste there you go and rubber grip
handles in colors little ones will love
they've got sensitive sonic vibrations
is gentle enough on your sensitive gums
and brush heads are automatically
delivered on a dentist recommended
schedule every three months for just
five dollars three out of four of us use
bristles that are old worn-out and
ineffective so don't do that
first the quip is one of the first
electric toothbrushes accepted by the
American Dental Association and has
thousands of verified five-star reviews
I love quip for keeping my teeth dentist
clean on the road and that's why I love
clip and why over 1 million happy
healthy mouths do - clip starts at just
$25 and if you go to get clip comm /
Congrats right now you can get your
first refill pack for free that's your
first refill pack free at GE tqu IP comm
/ Congrats cash app is brought to you by
congratulations the only app brought to
you by me Chris D'Elia that's how we do
it
that's how it is cash app is brought to
you by congratulations that's what they
wanted cash app is brought to you by
congratulations the only app brought to
you by me Chris D'Elia they're funky
Akash app dude that's why we that's why
we've dude that's why we [ __ ] with them
it's funky one time we were in Italy as
a family and my and my dad said get
dressed up we're going to dinner and my
brother put on a nice outfit and I put
on it what I thought was a nice outfit
and we walked to my parents hotel room
and my dad said hey Matt you look great
hey Chris you look funky and we never
let him live it down cuz we knew what he
was saying that I looked bad hey Chris
you look funky and we go immediately
we're like like the way I'm dressed
Matt you look nice Chris hey Chris you
look funky oh wow dude dad come on dude
come on dad
yeah dude we need of whatever man you
know I I did I remember when I was a kid
I was a [ __ ] my buddy Matt Rendon I
had a there was okay so there was this
kid who lived to the right of me and my
best friend Matt trevenna and then three
houses down to the left there was a girl
named Julie ratio PO and she was like
the first girl in my life that was like
a girl and like where I was like oh you
know girls were different than guys and
this is and this is a you know she's my
friend but also you know a girl and she
was like an 1 1 year older than me and
she would always like say like that Matt
was cool to me because like I would be
not my brother Matt Matt ramanan and I
think that she did it in my head maybe
was a defensive thing but I think she
did it like to make it seem like to did
like make me feel like upset you know
cuz like she liked him and not me and
then one time she said man Matt Matt has
a good butt and I was like oh yeah and
she was like yeah and I was like [ __ ]
and my head was like why doesn't she
think I have a good butt you know
and then she said well let me see your
butt
and I turn around and I remember I
flexed my butt so hard and she was like
yes he yours goes in and I realized oh
[ __ ] gonna flex tit because it goes
in if you flex it
I should just [ __ ] let it be plump
you know I should just let it [ __ ]
kind of just thought out I should have
just let myself be thick as [ __ ] dude
but I turned around and I flexed it so
so hard dude like so hard I flex my butt
so hard and she's like yeah yours goes
in and I was like no no no wait hold on
let me get a do-over do it I didn't say
it but I was like I yeah it's all been
Hager and Matt played soccer a lot to
those so his butt was probably better
than mine but I mean I do squats now you
know I don't think it's because of Julie
Recio pole but I you know I you know I'm
thick now dude I got a good butt
I got a [ __ ] good but you know I'm no
[ __ ] Mark McGwire but I got a good
butt um dad you gotta get that horse but
like a baseball player
baseball players got that horse but you
know like Mark McGwire bro
anybody that hits over 40 home runs they
got that horse but knock it out of the
park and just [ __ ] neigh around the
basis yeah anyway I was thinking about
this man I was thinking about I was in a
conversation with a bunch of people who
was I talking about this with about like
dan Bilzerian that guy that does all the
flying around with the chicks like I was
thinking about that and I was thinking
about how that's quote unquote every
guy's fantasy right to just have [ __ ]
you know ten chicks around you know the
Hugh Hefner thing right like we just got
ten chicks and you just Iran they're
around and you're just always around
them and all that [ __ ] and I was
thinking about like if they had that
choice like like
like here's the thing dude having sex
with a bunch of different women sure
that's I understand that want that's
cool and that's can be hot and it's
great whatever but what's up with this
guy though what's up with and the guy
seems happy and [ __ ] and no knock on the
dude the guy's [ __ ] doing what he
wants to do but you this guy's not doing
that he's like you got it oh you gotta
be on a plane with them for six hours
like that's the thing that I don't get
like this guy is always chillin with
them and I'm not saying it's not fun to
be around ten chicks I'm saying it's not
fun to be around ten thoughts it's not
it's it's it's not and and maybe there's
something wrong with me okay like but
like if Dan and he would never because
I'm boring as [ __ ] but if he asked me to
be like yo we're going to New York get
on the private jet these twelve thoughts
are gonna come with us I would be like
Oh bro I can't I can't go dude and then
he would be like but look at the girls
and I would be like yeah but they're
gonna talk and stuff what are I'd say
yeah but what are we gonna talk about
what are we gonna say I get one I get
having sex with all of the girls is fun
but then they're all at your house and
they're like where did I put my and
you're like oh I I don't know and the
girls like you're always losing [ __ ] and
then the other ones like well um hello
people just think I should be a comedian
cuz like I'm always losing stuff and I'm
really just commenting on it and then
other girls like you should be
and they just have a shirt on and I
gotta be like yeah you should be a
comedian or what what or what what do I
say to that if I'm in that situation I
go like this hey hey hey hey
no I just don't I don't get it I don't
get that life my I wish and I like I
said no knock on the [ __ ] dude and
the chicks are there having fun he's
having fun that's great you know it's
it's like me I don't want to [ __ ] go
to a football game you know I'm not I'm
never gonna look at another guy running
with a ball and [ __ ] actually be like
[ __ ] yeah like I hope for what he went
to the [ __ ] place he went to the end
see he doesn't even know who I am I
don't give a [ __ ] I get busted in common
but hanging I get Boston and common but
hanging I get Boston in common but on a
plane to New York I just don't I don't
know I don't get it maybe I like I think
a lot of guys I think a lot of guys
would not choose that right I want to
know what kind of guy would go on that
trip the girls are [ __ ] hot dude
they're all real hot not you know I'm
not gonna be one of those guys here's
who's annoying the guys like those girls
aren't even hot dude shut up dude shut
the [ __ ] up those girls are all hot hot
girls are hot girls yeah dude the guy
who's like you know I don't care if the
boobs aren't big if they're fake nah
dude shut up no knock on small boobs
that [ __ ] small boobs can be great
but
just cuz they're fake doesn't mean
they're bad yeah girls who get the
[ __ ] too much too much of the [ __ ]
nah not for me
you and your [ __ ] cubicle just fat
you know just [ __ ] how girls are hot
girls okay
my point is being on a plane with them
twelve of them when they're just doing
Instagram stories jumping out I'm gay
this how I'm having a conversation okay
cool then I'm just like this birds what
what what are you doing here oh dude
thoughts you know wha what are you doing
here why you why you jump out of the
plane
oh girl up there said she should be a
comedian and all of her friends think
that she should be a comedian you did
the right thing
[Laughter]
she said she's the silliest girl in the
world what are you doing down here
oh the girl up there said that one time
she met Tyga's brother yeah did the
right thing I mean dude what's wrong
with this world dude when you see a
[ __ ] picture in a club with a guy
with his shirt off and [ __ ] shorts on
and another guy dressed up like a
[ __ ] marshmallow you know you know
dude what's up Vegas you know
marshmallow DJ marshmallow I like when
he wears the [ __ ] marshmallow can hat
and also a white blazer like you dressed
up for the occasion
like he's like y'all I'm still
marshmallow but also this is my [ __ ]
and you know this is in case somebody's
it this is a [ __ ] business meeting
Wow look at the [ __ ] tux he's got a
tux on but still the marshmallow can hat
how dumb is that
you know maybe make skip music I don't
give a [ __ ] but like come on guys show
your face you know these guys who think
it's interesting I definitely talked
about this on the podcast before we
think it's like the rapper who thinks
it's interesting to not show his face
like dude show your face man it's all
good make music I'm marshmallow by the
way you guys don't know uh so yeah I
wanna I wanna I want to I don't know if
I will go on the plane with those guys
what do those guys talk about what do
they talk about for real the Lakers they
talk about the Lakers a lot right like
well you know Kobe you know I mean I
know people think he's great but you
know he'd now that there's LeBron they
don't [ __ ] include Kobe's one of the
goats but he is like they say stuff like
that and they definitely say stuff like
you know I russell westbrook like you
know we may not be the greatest player
but i'd rather have him on my team than
anyone else like they say that you know
he brings in ticket sales and he's also
you know I know he saw he's a selfish
player but nobody's more dynamic than
him that's what they say and and and and
and that makes me want to jump out of
[ __ ] plane so it's all good did you
see the Lakers by the way the [ __ ]
fan protest dude everyone that goes
there were a bunch of fans that came
that went to the Staples Center outside
of the Staples Center and protested
about how management was handling the
team anybody who did that anybody who
went on that protest you were the kinds
of people that if the world ended
we don't need you we don't need you
anymore okay we don't need you if you
were to take then the top people if you
had to whittle the world down if the
world ended you had to whittle it down
to the necessary people you'd be first
to go do you understand that the people
who stood outside of the Staples Center
and protested how management was dealing
with their team the Lakers hey guys you
guys were the first to go he understand
Lakers fan protests arguably a rock
bottom moment four storied franchise hey
man first of all you're in Lakers
jerseys like so [ __ ] ironic are you a
fan or not dude oh look I love the team
this is why I want to [ __ ] you're not
a part of it dude
you're not a part of it
George Murray and Jacob Samuel had seen
and heard enough the eighteen-year-old
Cassatt Calabasas high school students
weren't alive when Kobe Bryant and
Shaquille O'Neal won their first
championship together with the Lakers in
2000 there were eight when the Lakers
won their last title in 2010 they have
no vivid memories of the Lakers dynasty
they've heard about from friends and
family and they're tired of it so the
left school early Friday with five
classmates and made their one hour drive
to Staples Center to join about 30 other
Lakers fans protesting the leadership
and direction of the team the protest
took place the day before Frank Vogel
agreed to become the Lakers coach
Saturday afternoon hey guys your first
to go you understand that right you know
that though right so it's all good if
you know that if the if you're like look
I'm gonna drive from Calabasas to the
Lakers they're not gonna listen to me
I'm gonna put my Lakers Jersey on I'm
gonna argue and protest about how
they're dealing with the Lakers cuz I
haven't seen him win but I understand if
we had to widdle the population down and
the world was ending I'll be first to go
about 30 other Lakers fans not enough
amen not enough
you're like the [ __ ] Ross Perot of
the [ __ ] Presidential Debates Ross
Perot now by the way you don't matter
dude if I owned the Lakers and that [ __ ]
was happening
I'd go out there and just start [ __ ]
laughing
with only Asher not just a shirt on just
laughing a long shirt on to where you
could maybe see the tip of my dick out
but under it and then and then they'd
just be like dude what the [ __ ] man
and I'd be like it's my team blah and
then I go like this to whatever security
I say never allow them in my [ __ ]
stadium and then as I walk away I make
sure the night before I eat a whole
bunch of [ __ ] stuff that makes me
fart and then and then and then I went
to walk away every step I take I [ __ ]
fart to be the most disrespectful man
alive look at look at look at look at
look at look at this is on what's it
called complex calm the turnout for the
Lakers fan protest may have been more
embarrassing than team's season double
slam double slam took him to Denny's
complex took him [ __ ] both to Denny's
dude they were like hey Lakers fans and
Lakers management come on to Denny's
look at this play this what's this can
we play this meet Charlie rivers the 22
year old Lakers fan that organized
today's protests on reddit what is it
charlie I'll play it let me Charlie
rivers here we go here we go of course I
go on YouTube and a bunch of [ __ ]
guys a bunch of [ __ ] rivers come up
LA Times sports LA Times sports
here we go there we go there we go
Sports News other times calm Sports is
it on now is it up here what I do
Charlie rivers cool where's the search
button cool cool oh dude
do I want to get the newsletter nope not
interested everyone wants your [ __ ]
newsletter letter here we go if it
doesn't come up I'm pissed
nope didn't come up pissed I'm pissed
just email me the [ __ ] link and I'm
not gonna be logged in the email and
that's gonna piss me off
this is a live by plays out for us here
we go yeah I got it send it to me when
you can
did you send it to me I'm pissed
it's not in my inbox yeah I'm pissed yes
it's taking too long yes oh it doesn't
that one fire doesn't have email on the
[ __ ] thing dude yes Oh Elliot our
sports Twitter that's what it is you
didn't say Twitter now I didn't LA Times
sports Twitter this sucks dude this part
sucks on the podcast it's all good
though dude you're with us through thick
and thin man yes here we go here we go
yes how far down is it too far yes so
far down dude I'm not even logged into
Twitter yes you have email on the phone
just login dude [ __ ] man
goddamnit he's composing the email now
dude he's composing the email now dude
unreal dude some of you babies like this
[ __ ] the most that one [ __ ] [ __ ] up
it's all good and it's not in I forget
[Music]
dude did you email it to me or what when
what is it a [ __ ] junk mail oh here
we go finally do it Jesus Christ let's
see what this [ __ ] ass on I go
my god the video starts end go what is
this [ __ ] 2009 le rivers
I'm from Anaheim California born and
raised I crayon without in Phoenix I'm
20 years old and I'm out here from the
Staples Center
what keep people out here I'm in my
opinion hurt a few was right I just want
to make it clear that this protest is
not against the personal behaviors of
Jeanie buss programs winner Rambis I'm
trying to find people on a personal
level this is about their direction
they're taking basketball operations at
the moment hey dude you know what you
don't have to do is tell us what this
protest isn't okay because we barely
give a [ __ ] what it is all right well
first of all I want to tell you what is
it's not about you know it's not about
Jeanie buss and anybody on a personal
level it's also not about any of the
things going on with the Avengers and
Avengers franchise and we know that the
Avengers have been a lot of talk in the
media lately it's also not about
anything that is not about what I'm
about to say right now
now tell me tell me why you you guy who
is interviewing I mean who's worse dude
okay so um okay um all right so uh this
is what can be missing but head right
here the direction to taking basketball
operations at the moment
now tell me tell me why you you you are
the one that and Internet's cognize the
event your erratic he told me a little
bit more about that well quite frankly I
don't consider myself different from
anybody else I'm just a person like
anybody here I would be the first to go
if they willed the population down I
would literally be the first person to
be gone I would just be another mouth to
feed
and I would be taking up space so if the
apocalypse happened I would absolutely
be the first to go I never know is that
I just gave my opinion person told me
you know what if you care about so much
why don't you organize protest so that's
what I realized I care about the wrong
things and I care about wrong things too
much people are dying people are hungry
people there's an AIDS epidemic and
people are homeless and I decided to
drive all the way out to the Staples
Center to complain didn't it's an
impromptu protest happen on Wednesday
evening
it's Friday noon it's about day and a
half
and here we are dude how did you
organize that in just a day and a half
how'd you organize this protest with 30
people in one day and one half fairly of
the news coverage now tell me how the
reddit community played a role into
getting the same off the ground what do
you mean off the ground dude there's 29
people there what do you mean how did
you use reddit to get this off the
ground
this isn't viral 29 people are there uh
hello
there's one-fifth of that in my house
right now
publicity they literally were like
worried
here we go they literally had to think
should we carpool or should we we could
all fit making a go viral making it it's
not viral making it be seen by the news
and media outlets and the sports
journalists and beat writers they so
tremendous positive feedback and of
course with anything else there was also
negative backlash but the majority of it
was positive people
when you drove was in Phoenix Arizona
specifically for this process in that I
am bitching to be as big on the news as
it became but due to the response and
feedback that I had I decided to drive
out from Phoenix Thursday night dude
nobody's there he's talking about this
and nobody's there the [ __ ]
oh man this is but here's no here's
another guy here's another guy off [ __ ]
I love when it's a woman I love when
it's a white guy
I [ __ ] love when it's a white guy
dude this is scholars and course it is
by the way why the [ __ ] is everybody
from phoenix arizona dude this is the
lakers go to a [ __ ] son's game
witnessing what's going on right now
with the lakers organization draws in a
lot of similarities and to be able to be
a part of this chaos one as an NBA fan
but more importantly as a Phoenix Suns
fan I'd be lying if I didn't say there
was a little bit of enjoyment being
taken from this but I can empathize with
this whole thing the decisions the front
office that management is a complete
catastrophe related to the fan base of
this wonderful organization hate to say
that the truth is truth lakers deserve
better they deserve some common sense in
this space but it's going to take a
little bit of chaos before they arrive
on that eventual new plateau and this is
part of that this is part of change this
is part of the history the lakers
organization and i just want to be a
witness in this going on don't phoenix
but wish all the best really no ill will
on that now look what [ __ ] the guys got
to the Lupino
we're here at Showtime right now alright
gotta have some snacks you've got to be
able to keep your salt content up yeah
different fancy to anybody else you're
trying to get out by the way how [ __ ]
annoying is for our sporting event like
the only time you would ever crack
peanuts and eat peanuts is at a [ __ ]
ballgame that's so annoying
nobody wants [ __ ] peanuts what are we
[ __ ] elephants dude you go to a
ballgame and you're like yeah let's get
some [ __ ] peanuts like an elegant
like a [ __ ] CUDA dude you just follow
all the trends man oh yeah you pillage
it are cool yeah don't eat hot dogs if I
go to Dodge game dolly 12 hot dogs the
[ __ ] Cudas guy brought peanuts to a
protest hey man you're first to go
imagine bringing peanuts to a protest
dude come on just actually think about
waking up getting dressed taking a
shower going to get peanuts driving over
not opening the peanuts yet because
you're gonna save them for when you get
to the protest okay you're first to go
all right that's good
you know I mean what the [ __ ] else we
got talking about we covered it man we
covered it my babies down let's just
skip it all so you can download the cash
app for free on the App Store or Google
Play market and that's what you can do
and we've got remember shows at the Late
Show Edmonton Alberta Canada on Saturday
still tickets left and then Victoria BC
Vancouver which has been Coover Island I
believe Late Show and that's Sunday and
there are still tickets left so go and
get them and come to the
follow-the-leader tour and that's it
and what else did I did we have to
[ __ ] is that it that's it that's it
download the app you can see the show
before live before anyone else and
Krista Lea app and you guys thanks for
being with me man you guys are great and
we'll catch you soon
my babies have a good one
[Music]